ukraine is on fire
the country is being decimated before
the eyes of the world
the impact on civilians is reaching
terrifying proportions
and with each passing hour
two things are increasingly clear
first
it kept getting worse
second
whatever the outcome
this war will have no winners
only losers
as millions of people in ukraine face
hunger and dwindling supplies of water
and medicine
i'm announcing today that the united
nations will allocate a further 40
million us dollars from the central
emergency response fund
to ramp up vital assistance to reach the
most vulnerable as we wait for the
nations to come
this funding will help get critical
supplies of food water medicines and
other life-saving aids into the country
as well as provide
cash assistance to the needy
further escalation of the war whether by
accident or design
threatens all of humanity
raising the alert of russian nuclear
forces is a bone-chilling development
the prospect of nuclear conflict once
unthinkable
is now back within the realm of
possibility
the security and safety of nuclear
facilities must also be preserved
it's time to stop the order unleashed on
the people of ukraine and get on the
path of diplomacy and peace
yes we are doing our best uh i've talked
with the number of leaders that are in
permanent contact with the president
putin and of course we consider that is
absolutely essential
for
an effort an additional effort to make
the russian federation understand that
this war
is becoming an absolute nightmare and to
create the conditions for
the
war to be stopped and for serious
negotiations to be put in place
whenever there are reliable accounts of
humanitarian law abuse
we should be ready
to react swiftly
therefore
we welcome the decision of a permanent
council
of march referred to invoke the moscow
mechanism to create a group of
independent experts to investigate the
reported violation of humanitarian law
in the context of the hostilities in
ukraine
we recognize the extensive efforts
which foreign minister rao described
which the osce has made to try and avoid
this catastrophe
russia was offered a chance to raise any
security concerns in the osce renewed
european security dialogue
but said it was not the right time
we now know they were planning war all
along
ukraine and others invoked the osce
vienna document risk reduction mechanism
to seek transparency from russia and
belarus and to de-escalate the situation
russia refused to engage
and of course the osce has worked for
years to support implementation of the
minsk agreements
russia is accused of the gravest war
crimes
bombing schools hospitals and homes
targeting families as they try to run to
safety
we welcome action taken under the moscow
mechanism to hold russia to account
the osce fact-finding mission must be
given full access so that evidence can
be gathered
by listening to the statement of the
chairperson office of the usc
what he would talk about even before he
took the floor and that's what you did
we are surprised
and this is not the first time
way beyond the remit of impartiality
we're surprised by her statement
stipulated uh under her obligations as
an international civil servant
and uh
information
or a representative of one of the member
states
you
uh you uh strike bomb by the ukrainian
armed forces
it was filled uh with cluster bombs and
that struck the heart of donetsk
as a result
a blind eye to what's happening
and in the conditions
in which people are living under
constant shelling
in
uh
apparently from a russian
shot
regret any
people who die in a conflict
i just like to make two clarifying
points
was not actually journalist activity it
was uh filmmaking and that's uh on open
access that information
controlled by the ukrainian armed forces
and the ukrainian uh
it was them who opened fire on their
would in vehicles way be on cooperation
between the un and the osce
the demand for cooperation over recent
years has sharpened a decrease due to it
by a certain cover statement to replace
the charter by a rules-based order
to the east of vienna
down to just one subject
so much unprofessional
in fact
we had substantive talks with him
only in the middle of march though
foreign
campaign in the osce